there's no convincing trump that he lost
but we thought we would try now advisers
we saw kellyanne conway talk about
friends everybody tried to tell him uh
the courts
but uh we thought we'd take one last
shot at it and we wrote a children's
book
um it's called pack your [ __ ] and go
uh and we thought it's
the last show while he's president where
i can [ __ ] on this guy
i've tried to be even-handed the whole
time he was president but it didn't work
out but would you like to hear some of
uh pack your [ __ ] and go
all right all the votes if encountered
all the courts have said no you're all
out of options now pack your [ __ ] and go
it's clear that you're angry that you're
feeling quite low that feeling's called
losing
so pack your [ __ ] and go
pick up a new hobby like knitting or
banjo call your favorite hooker
just pack your [ __ ] and go
start a cable network try talk radio
there's an opening at limbaugh
but you gotta pack your [ __ ] and go
cause you treated your job like a
reality show well now it's been canceled
so pack your [ __ ] and go
you